[Music]
let's talk about the the training
yourself to be uncomfortable or to
become more comfortable with discomfort
does anything come to mind just in terms
of managing your psychology for my own
psychology the way that i try to manage
this stuff is i wake up in the morning
and you get like whatever emails you
have of like stuff that's going on in
the world right so it's world events
it's team events whatever trends we're
seeing across our our products
and often in there there's a fair amount
of
bad news and like new things that i need
to absorb
one of the things i found that just for
kind of managing my myself
is that
if i try to just go straight into the
day
it's like almost every morning when i
wake up and like read read through my my
emails and get the news it's like
it's almost like getting punched with
sort of like a ton of new context and
it's like okay i need to like
internalize this so i found that
basically doing
something physical
and and something that's like meditative
to take my mind off of it for like an
hour so then i can reset and go do work
is really important so that's why you
know things like foiling or surfing have
been really important to me because you
know when you're out there in the water
it's like pretty hard to focus on
anything else right it's i mean it's
like you when you're on the board you're
focused on making sure you stay on the
board and don't mess something up and
especially if you're if you're kind of
towing or something like that there's
not a whole lot of downtime yeah
i found that for my own performance is
significantly better when i have
something like that that's like
meditative and
and physical and and allows me to kind
of output some energy and then i can
come back in and it's almost like i'll
have subconsciously settled all of the
things that that have sort of all the
news that have happened in the world now
it's like okay let's go deal with it
yeah no obviously if there's something
that's really an emergency not gonna you
know go to a sport or something i'll go
deal with it and obviously part of life
is you you don't always get to control
your schedule and that's kind of how
that goes but you know when i compare
kind of how i do
on the days when i kind of get to have
some time to soak that in or to to kind
of have an outlet versus
just like jumping right in i find them
often like stewing and bad news or
something and then i just i like i'm not
i'm not as productive so i think that's
sort of my own personal way that i try
to manage situations like this but
obviously
a key part of this is like having an
awesome team and and it's not it's not
you know primarily about me at this
point you know it's a big company and we
have awesome people who are who are
running all these different groups so i
get that what i'm what i'm saying kind
of how i've worked out the system for
myself isn't necessarily something that
would work for a lot of other people
i think the the meditative palette
cleanser makes sense though especially
if you're talking about things like
foiling where the
consequence of a lapse of attention on
what you're doing has immediate
penalties yeah so it's regulating in a
sense maybe i'm not strong-willed enough
or like or or calm enough to just do
straight-up meditation it's like i
actually need to put myself in a
situation where it's difficult to not
focus on that thing
yeah but i don't know i mean i think
part of this too and i do think managing
energy is an interesting thing i mean
some of the the folks who i work with
the company they say this lovingly but i
think that they sometimes refer to my
attention as the eye of sauron in that
basically
you have this unending amount of energy
to go work on on something and if you
and if you like point that at any given
team you will just burn them but at the
same time right it's managing that so
that way i can like manage my own energy
and diffuse it well enough so that way
it's like okay i i have the thing that
i'm focused on that that day and i it's
really important to me that i can
as often as possible manage my schedule
so i can actually focus on the things
that i'm naturally thinking about i just
think the engagement that you get of
having like a an immediate feedback loop
around thinking about something then
going to getting to go talk to the
people who are working on this is so
much better than like going and
scheduling a meeting that you'll have
three weeks later when i mean maybe the
topic will still be important but it's
not like what's going on at that time
yeah getting that balance right is an
important thing for sustainability for
the organization as well
you